i was remember i was reading a book
years ago on preparing for a marathon
and one of the chapters again uh was on
the psychology of it and it said this
verbatim you know because i'm the memory
expert it said you're my your your brain
is like a super computer and your
self-talk is a program that will run so
if you tell yourself you're not good at
remembering names you will not remember
the name of the next person you meet
because you program your super computer
not to
and i always tell people that um and and
now i i don't i don't think the brain is
like a super computer it's i think it's
a it's a weak metaphor for for uh for
what it is because you know this is like
a living computer that could do so much
more and has different um capabilities
but i would say that um your self-talk
is important and it is the program that
we will run and i always tell people to
keep it positive keep it empowering
because
your mind is always eavesdropping on
your self-talk
right and you have to be careful what
you say to yourself because it's this
unconscious command so i would be very
careful like when i'm get when i get
nervous or i feel like i'm i think some
of the most successful people live at
the edge of their limits you know and
they and they play there also as well
and so whenever i feel in my nervous
system i feel like i can't do it then i
feel like i really must do it because i
feel like how we do anything is how we
do everything
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the 10
habits that you can start this month to
change your life
enjoy
habit number two set an intention with
mel robbins i have this habit of every
single morning i stand in front of the
mirror and i take a moment and i raise
my hand and i give my reflection a high
five and there is so much science behind
this so instead of seeing yourself
right and have having this moment in the
mirror you know what the average person
does first of all we beat ourselves down
so i would look in the mirror for 40
some years and be like oh my god my
freaking jowls look like saddlebags on a
goddamn horse going in the grand canyon
my eyes have my neck is only striped my
boob one boobs hanging lower than the
other it looked like my gray hair like i
start bringing myself down
and when you start going down that road
with your reflection
then your thoughts go to i didn't get to
that email i forgot to text lisa back i
oh my gosh the dog still needs to be
walked i've got nine minutes for my
first zoom you're now
checking out
and that moment in the mirror every
morning
could be a profound moment
where you lift yourself up
and you check back in with your
intention
so the first piece of research and this
is recent from harvard business school
is that a simple moment
in the morning
where you set an intention
about who you're going to be today
impacts productivity
how you show up as a leader
it impacts your confidence it impacts
your mood all day long just that simple
moment of setting an intention so that's
research number one instead of
standing in front of the sink in your
bathroom and criticizing your appearance
or mindlessly going on autopilot
check back in and let's teach you to
make it a habit to lift yourself back up
second piece of research and this comes
from a whole field of study called
neurobics neurobics is like aerobics for
your mind i didn't make this up
this is literally you can speed up the
development of new neural pathways by
marrying physical activity
with a change in thought
and so traditionally i know you've
covered this on your show if you for
example were to brush your teeth i'm a
right-hander if you were to brush it
with your other hand and think
a new thought
the fact that your brain is focusing on
brushing with your non-dominant hand
activates more focus on the new thought
it accelerates the learning so you take
neurobics a physical activity with a
different thought and let me let's talk
about a high five for example
what does a high five mean to you
that somebody did something awesome or i
did something awesome correct and if you
think about the times in your life when
you've gotten a high five
it's because somebody's like tom you're
amazing tom get your attitude out of the
can you got this tom you're gonna make
this shot tom we can still win i believe
in you keep going
you have a lifetime
positive association with giving other
people high fives stored right here in
your subconscious mind when you raise
your hand to your own reflection it is
impossible for you to think god i look
fat why am i an [ __ ] i really screwed
up my life you can't do it because your
lifetime association with this motion is
all i believe in you i got you i see you
i celebrate you and so you in the moment
of doing it override decades of negative
self-talk it's incredible
now have you ever gotten a high five
where somebody misses the hand or it's
sort of like it sucks right yeah what do
you do when that happens i redo it
correct
that's because a high five requires you
to be present and there is an intention
behind it
so you can't raise your hand to your own
reflection without now grounding
yourself in the moment habit number
three be deliberate with andrew huberman
if i finish a chapter
i will
stop for a moment and i'll just kind of
smile and laugh at myself i'm big on
like
self-reflection with humor and just
thinking this is crazy you know
my brain is under my control there would
be people out there that say there's no
free will but i do not believe that i
put my hands in a lot of brains you
stimulate certain brain areas people do
things you stimulate other brain areas
people think things
ultimately unless you have electrodes in
your head and someone's stimulating them
we are in control of our thoughts and
behaviors we can't control all of them
but my goal is to be as
you know deliberate and non-reflexive as
possible in life that's my goal from
when i wake up in the morning until i go
to sleep how do we get to that place
little by little and by rewarding each
thing if you get up
and you
used to make the bed exam make the bed
you're you're not back on your heels you
make a cup of coffee you sit down you
script out something in a journal you
exercise maybe you call a relative that
you think might you need to hear from
you or that you'd like to talk to you do
something
in a deliberate way just being
deliberate and learning to push away the
things that are trying to make you
reflexive is so important habit number
four start and learn with mark randolph
the
idea you start with uh it didn't work
but it's a starting point but once you
start you actually begin learning what
might be the path to something that will
work i mean in netflix's case it took a
long time
but it doesn't mean that it's not a fun
process or that it's a it's a process in
itself you're actually moving forward
even though you know you haven't figured
it out yet i mean certainly when we
started netflix was not streaming video
it was dvd
it was mailing dvds and for those people
who might actually be familiar with the
netflix dvd service now it wasn't like
it is now it wasn't a subscription
service
it was due dates it was late fees i mean
it was
looking back on it ridiculous
and so of course it didn't work i mean
the occasional person would rent from us
but they wouldn't rent a second time it
was really hard to find someone who was
willing to do it more than once
but
we
learned we tried things we tested things
and each time you do a test
even though it may not solve the problem
completely it does illuminate the path
forward just a little bit at the very
least you've learned what doesn't work
and you can try a different direction
and little by little in our case took a
year and a half
but eventually you finally if you're
lucky stumble onto the business model
that actually does work that's
repeatable and scalable
and where you can actually lo and behold
charge more for it than it costs you to
deliver the service
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number five find balance
with radanov swami one time
i was going through a lot of trials in
my life
because everyone does
whether you're living
for a spiritual purpose or a
material purpose or anything else
the nature of the world
is there's going to be challenges
there's going to be setbacks
because just like there's two sides of a
coin in america we call it heads and
tails
so similarly
life is like a coin
and
wherever there's happiness the other
side is distress there's health there's
disease
honor dishonor pleasure pain success
development failure
birth death it's a world of dualities
and
that coin is always going to flip over
and there's not that much we can do
about it however much we know however
much we have
there's
a little space
between the heads and the tails the rim
yes
and in that place we actually find
balance
and that's very important that balance
between people
the the balance the harmony between the
body the mind
and the spirit
that's
the place where our relationships can
can be real can be fulfilling and can be
sustainable habit number six change your
perspective with marie forleo i was
believing that if i didn't work
constantly
that i wasn't a worthy person
that i wasn't
doing enough to make my business
successful that i was perhaps letting
people down and so i had to really shift
that and understand that you know i come
from a background
i don't come from a wealthy background
so the work ethic in my nuclear family
is very strong like my my dad owned a
small business my mom
although she stayed home with us she was
constantly doing stuff constantly
working constantly fixing things
constantly doing things that took care
of the family so that's the kind of dna
i grew up with was like
no if something needs to get done you
get it done it's not like you sit around
all day and eating bon bons and watching
tv yeah yeah
so um yeah so so that's kind of how i
got there but then i really i had to
readjust if i actually wanted to not
only have a successful business but have
a successful life habit number seven try
on new values with mark manson let's say
i'm just really superficial and i value
money more than anything like i've got
like a fleet of yachts and it's it's all
i care about you know um
and then something happens in my life
and i realize that
that's pretty superficial i should like
grow up a bit and you know value
something else and
it's not as simple as just deciding like
we've all had that experience in our
lives where
we wish we cared about something that we
don't or vice versa we wish we didn't
care about something that we do and you
can't just stop
um and so the the process that i
describe in the book is that essentially
before you can commit to a new value you
kind of have to like
try them on like like it's like going to
a store and trying on a bunch of pairs
of clothes
and the way you try on a new value is
you need to sit down and visualize and
you can even write it out if you want
but it's like let's say all i care about
is my fleet of boats and uh and i want
to try on a new value
like charity or something
i have to sit down and start asking
myself what would it mean for my life
what would it mean for me as a person if
i didn't value
those boats anymore
[Music]
and that's a very hard question it
really
it messes us up because we realized that
a lot of our relationships would
probably fall apart a lot of our
business commitments would probably fall
apart um
a lot of our understanding of ourselves
would be shaken up or or questioned
and it's a very
difficult thing to ask um
and so
you know most of the times when you see
visualization taught in the self-help
industry it's like they take a guy who
wants a fleet of boats and they say
visualize a fleet of boats now go get it
and it's like no no what you need to do
is take a guy who wants a fleet of boats
and say visualize not wanting a fleet of
boats what would that say about you who
would you be
if that thing you always desired was not
your desire anymore habit number eight
figure out your routine with glennon
doyle i can only do creative work in the
morning i can do business like when you
know after the kids get off to school i
can do business i can do like an
interview i can do um work but i can't
do anything creative and i actually
don't know anything after like i know
all the things in the morning yeah i'm
so wise
for like an hour and a half
and it's just all gone so i just have to
like um grab that time
and if i do that every day and also for
me creating and writing is is i mean i
would hope my kids wouldn't see this
part but it's like the most important
thing to me
so
i feel like i like them also but i
you're nice i like you you and you yeah
i mean i created them also so i feel
good about that that's creative but for
me to feel
fulfilled like i've done my work for the
day i have to do that in the morning
and then i don't care what happens after
that yeah like i've done all all the
hardest things the most important things
before anybody wakes up so the rest of
the day is like gravy how about number
nine
habit number nine be honest with
yourself with lewis howes do you have
any tips about how you've learned how to
be honest with yourself versus avoiding
i think it's hard sometimes it just
depends on the situation and and what
we're talking about but
[Music]
i'm not sure if i really have advice on
how to be
honest with yourself
i think
when you know something is off
whether it be
a career you're working in or a
relationship or
something you need to tell someone in
your family or whatever it may be when
you know something is off that's when
you should listen to yourself and
pay attention
and if you're not paying attention doing
it and saying okay maybe this is going
to be you know
hurt
by being honest
it's hurting yourself more by not
sharing
than by sharing and i think
you've got to be discerning on every
situation and everything is
unique and you've got to be
aware
of
the timing of when you're saying things
and stuff like that but
the the more honest you can be i think
the better at least with yourself
um and just be aware of what feels right
and what doesn't feel right and habit
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus glimpse is choose to be
happy with dorago paul das a lady who
was over 90 years old but had a great
flair towards dressing up well applying
makeup and arranging her hair in
beautiful patterns
she and her husband had been married to
each other for 70 years
after the departure of her beloved
partner having no children and no one in
the family to care for her
she decided
to move
to a nursing home
even on the day
when she vacated her home for good
she dressed up eloquently and looked
gorgeous
after arriving at the nursing home she
had to wait patiently in the lobby for
hours before her room was ready
when an attendant helped her make her
way to the room
she gave the lady a visual description
of the tiny space that she was meant to
occupy
i
love it the lady expressed with the
enthusiasm of an eight-year-old who had
just been presented with a new puppy
mrs jones you haven't even seen the room
yet just wait the attendant remarked
well
my joy has nothing to do with the room
the lady replied
whether i like my room or not
doesn't depend
on how the furniture is arranged
it depends on how i arrange my mind
happiness is something you can decide
ahead of time
and i've already decided to love my room
to love the people around me to love my
life
it is a decision that i make every
morning when i wake up
you know what
the greatest asset we all have
is
the power to choose how we feel
the lady continued speaking as the
attendant listened attentively with her
mouth
wide open
i can spend my entire day in bed
thinking of the pain i am in focusing on
those parts of my body that no longer
work
or
i can get out of bed and be thankful for
those parts that do work
each day is a gift and as long as my
eyes can still open i will continue to
focus on today and all the happy
memories i have stored in my mind
just for this time in my life the
attendant was astounded by the positive
attitude of the elderly lady whose life
from an external point of view was only
full of problems and hopelessness
ladies and gentlemen
only problems happen automatically
happiness
is a choice we all have to make
only
anger happens automatically peace is a
choice we all have to make only hatred
happens automatically love is a choice
we all have to make being negative
happens automatically a positive
attitude is a choice we all have to make
complaining is automatic
gratitude is a choice we all have to
make
choose right
and
live well
the number one way to deal with negative
people in your life is through empathy
it's empathy it's not it's not hating
them back it's not spreading negativity
it's not reminding yourself that you're
better than them it's it's empathy
and it's not even just feeling bad for
them
it's actually connecting to them
let me let me explain
i default assuming that people are good
this is a wild idea
people are good humans are good i've
done the who exercise the year one word
exercise helping people find the most
important core value with so many people
and
it's always something positive
i believe that ninety nine point nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine percent of
people are good there's a tiny tiny tiny
percentage of people who enjoy killing
people and maybe have you know a few
screws loose up here but for the most
part we're good everybody has dreams
everybody has ambitions everybody wants
to serve everybody wants to be in a
better place than where they are right
now
the problem is
a lot of people are afraid a lot of
people are in pain a lot of people are
struggling a lot of people are suffering
a lot of people have tried they took
their shot and and it didn't work out
and because they're so in pain now they
don't want other people around them to
have success either
because if they took a shot
and it didn't work out
it's they don't want to own it that it's
on them but if you then go off and have
success you start achieving your goals
what does that say about them right it's
not that the world is rigged against
them it's that they actually suck and
they don't want to admit that and they
don't want to own up to that and so
they're living in pain
and so they take it out and other people
they take it out on you they take it out
on me they take it out on on the world
they take it out on people right that's
what that's what people do when they're
in a lot of pain think about you think
about your experiences your life think
about when you've been in a lot of pain
when you've struggled really think about
this the last time that you were
struggling in a lot of pain did you then
show up as your best self in all
situations
did you maybe lose your cool on somebody
did you maybe
insult somebody did you maybe say
something that you're not proud of that
you later would regret
has that ever happened to you so that
you're a bad person it's not that you're
a toxic person it's not that you're a
hater
you were just in a lot of pain
and so the people who are throwing shade
at you are in a lot of pain they're
struggling
and just recognizing that just trying to
put yourself in their shoes and look at
their life
and if you know them you can actually
look at their life and if you don't know
them you can assume things about their
life
if if somebody's coming to leave in a
negative comment on your youtube video
the fact that that is the highlight of
their day
speaks volumes about them
right if the best part of your day is
going to somebody's youtube channel
leaving some nasty comment that gets you
feeling good
you're in a lot of just imagine the pain
that that person's in imagine what their
life is like right now
and it's a bit of a mental exercise
because at the beginning
the natural reaction is to be defensive
like well no i'm not this and how could
you call me that
and
we want the people around to support us
and cheer us on and tell us that we're
doing the right thing so the natural
defense mechanism kicks in where
we say no i'm that's not that's not
right but if you take a breather you can
take a step back and you can just
try to have empathy try to put yourself
in their shoes try to see that they're
in a lot of pain
what it does is removes the sting from
the words it removes the venom from the
words
it doesn't get you to react
as emotionally it allows you to show up
more as your best self
it's it's one of the most valuable
things you can start to practice this is
one of the things that prevents people
from creating content from posting
videos from sharing their thoughts
you've got a big mission a message your
story can change people's lives you your
story your story can change people's
lives it will change people's lives and
we're afraid to do it
because of how
people that we don't know or people that
we do know will judge us
we're afraid that we're going to get
negative comments and that's the reason
why you're not putting your message out
there we have to learn you have to learn
to stop getting in your own way and to
start
sharing
to start releasing to start living your
life the life that you want not somebody
else's version of it
people are going to judge you
it doesn't say anything about you
it talks about them their mental state
the pain that they're in the struggle
that they're in the suffering they're in
right now so step number one is have
empathy empathy empathy empathy try to
try to put yourself in their shoes
understand the pain that they're going
through
and and it removes the emotion from what
they're saying and how they're behaving
okay step number two is then is there
any validity in what they're saying
sometimes
there's actually some truth to what
they're saying even even if it's only
one percent truth if it's 99
negativity and one percent truth a lot
of times you know when a customer writes
in maybe they're really upset maybe
maybe they feel cheated maybe they feel
ripped off maybe they feel you didn't do
your job maybe they're maybe they got
cut off in traffic in a really bad mood
today right but maybe they're calling in
to cancel or they get a refund from you
maybe there's some validity in what
they're saying before we just write off
somebody and say you're a negative
person you're toxic i don't want you in
my life maybe there's actually some
truth they presented it very poorly
the packaging was terrible right the
packaging sucked but maybe there's some
validity in the message maybe there's
part truth that you can learn from and i
think this is really important because
if you can only learn from people
who package things really nicely who
sugarcoat everything who put in this
beautiful you know bow they say i love
you and you're amazing and keep doing
what you're doing and i have one little
tiny bit of feedback that maybe you
could learn from like maybe this one
little thing but i love you and you're
amazing like if that's the only way that
you can receive feedback you're never
gonna get the feedback you need to win
sometimes people will rage on you
sometimes people will yell at you
sometimes people will be rude to you
sometimes people will call you names
sometimes people will freak out it's
going to happen
is there any truth right once you can
remove the sting because you have
empathy for them
now you can actually see what they're
saying and see which you can use what
you can digest and what is worth
digesting what you're just going to
discard
because there might be truth
buried somewhere inside of their words
that can make you better that can still
help you that can that can improve your
life and your situation your business
and where you're trying to go so step
number one remove the sting set number
two look for the truth if there is now
there may be some that is just negative
but don't just default to thinking
negative default to thinking maybe
there's a lesson i can learn here and
step number three is then just decide
can you still be around these people or
not this is especially when they're in
your life where they're friends with
their family the people you're seeing
you might have to disconnect for a while
you might have to
because you're not strong enough yet you
might have to
not be around them
because their words hurt too much still
you might have to go and build build
your muscle build your empathy muscle
muscle build your empathy and build your
empathy muscle say that 10 times fast
you might have to go build that muscle
and that means you you spend less time
with them or kick them out of your life
ultimately though
what i see
leaders entrepreneurs you i think you're
a tree and i wrote about this in my book
built to serve i think you're a tree
what does a tree do a tree breathes in
the carbon dioxide which
too much of for humans is poison we
breathe the trees will breathe it in
they'll eat it they'll grow from it and
then they'll spit out oxygen positivity
for the world i see that as part of our
role as leaders and as entrepreneurs is
to eat other people's negativity grow
from it get better from it and then spit
out more positivity more oxygen for the
world ultimately the people who are
negative in your life you have an
ability to influence them you have an
ability to help them see the positive
road not through your
advice but through your actions by you
going off and doing your thing
will inspire other people to want to
change their life as well whoever is
more confident wins and when you're
around
really negative people
if you are doubting your positivity
they're going to win they're going to
drag you down
but ultimately the goal is to get so
positive so optimistic so
so happy
that you pull them up that you're more
positive you're more certain in your
positivity than they are certain in
their negativity and you pull them
towards making a better life decision
don't press news
snooze doesn't help by the way snooze is
one of those things that just simply is
a dream killer yeah it's like a snooze
bottom and kill your dreams that's the
answer yeah it's like a complete i think
it's gonna help you dream more but it's
not it's gonna destroy your dreams it's
a whole psychological trick
if you press news the thing that you
think expressing the snooze helps you
with like just get that extra eight
minutes of sleep that eight minutes the
sleep doesn't give you any more energy
by the way 18 seconds
there's there's an 18 second window
in the morning when your alarm goes off
that sucks it's about 18 seconds so 18
like the alarm goes off and you touch it
yeah the next 18 seconds are like a hard
there that's when you have to use
maximum effort to clear the
gravitational pull of your pillow
if you can get away from those 18
seconds
then you're okay you just get get away
from the pillow it's pulling you in like
yeah some tractor feed
you need to get away from that problem
so the 18 seconds and once you're up and
you're moving you're good when i wake up
in the morning um the first thing i do
is i do a gratitude exercise where i ask
myself usually in bed what am i most
grateful for today
and usually you know i'm grateful for my
health i'm grateful for my wife i'm
grateful for my children i'm grateful to
be alive i'm grateful you know for my
family i'm grateful to to have
experiences and you do you do that eyes
closed yeah i do that eyes closed and
while i
while i think about that i feel it and
so the feeling starts every day with a
great feeling
so i start every day with a great
feeling you have do you visualize some
things
like your children or do you talk to
yourself how do you do that yeah i have
an internal dialogue um i see images of
the things that i'm thinking about and
that just takes me two minutes just two
minutes when i wake up
and then
i go to exercise to take care of my body
how long um usually one hour to an hour
and 15 minutes every day
and so i do
a variety of different things i hike i
bike i work on aerobics i work on
strength i work with weights i do
whatever it is i just do it to give my
body the physical exercise
then as soon as i finish my exercise in
my gym
around
half an hour an hour 15 minutes at the
moment
so then in my gym i have uh two things i
have a vision board which is my dream
board for my
you are known for that yes so i have my
vision board for my my physique and my
body and my health
but then i also have in my gym something
called an achieved board okay so after i
achieved some of the things that i
achieved best and future no achieved in
the past yes so past you have the past
and the future
so
i have in my in my gym in my home gym i
have a
like a place where i sit and before i
start my meditation
i look at my vision board from the past
okay so i get connected to the different
things that i've been able to achieve
and i remember every day
when i set my mind and my focus
to achieving goals
i can achieve all of my goals what i
also do is i reinforce
most people focus on what's not working
this isn't going well this didn't work i
want to remind myself every day
of look how many things i was able to
accomplish
by being clear by being passionate by
using these rituals so before i go into
my meditation which is with my eyes
closed
i look at my achieved board i get
emotionally associated with it to remind
myself that when i set my mind to
achieve something
i can do it
and then i look across because i have a
mirror
in the gym and i look across and i say i
love you just the way you are and i said
i accept you just the way you are with
all of your skills and passion and
faults and insecurities and doubts and
fears i accept you just the way you are
and i smile
and then i close my eyes
and i do about a 15-minute meditation
and
in my meditation sometimes i have
no thoughts where i'm just one with the
universe and everything
other times i'll just follow my thoughts
and i'll just pay attention be mindful
of where are they going this morning
where are they going today
so i'll follow my thoughts and i'll just
follow them
other times i'll follow a thought and
say release that one
and follow another thought and say
release that one so i'm teaching my
brain
that i'm in control of my brain the
first 60 minutes or so are
very clearly defined and that's the
recipe i use to set up the rest of the
day step number one i wake up
and i meditate for 20 minutes typically
22 minutes it's 20 minutes of seated
transcendental meditation it could be
vipassana it could be head space and
then two-minute decompression period
where i sit there and let my mind do
whatever it wants to do i get up
brew tea very frequently oolong tea or
some combination of say
turmeric ginger and pouare that's
another favorite then i sit down to
journal and there are two different
types of journaling that i do depending
on the day
for different purposes one would be
morning pages where i'm effectively
vomiting my brain onto the page to trap
my monkey mind in print so that it
doesn't bother me for the rest of the
day the other type of journaling i do
is best encapsulated in a journal called
the five minute journal there are
different ways to do this but i'm
writing down three or four bullets of
items or people relationships anything
that i'm grateful for
which is a very very very nice
way to set the rest of the day so that
you're
viewing life through a lens of
positivity then there are a few
questions related or prompts i should
say related to focal points for the day
ideally immediately after that i'm
having a small amount to eat and then i
would go into exercise of some type that
exercise could be
riding on a peloton bike and doing a
20-minute hit workout high-intensity
interval training or it could be
acroyoga or it could be
weight training or working on a concept
2 rower
and that would be generally no more than
60 to 90 minutes in length sometimes as
short as 20 minutes
and then shower off to the day walk me
through a day in the life what's it look
like right now well i mean it's got to
be crazy
right now i i leave here and i fly out
to oregon
and i'll be in oregon with uh cameron
haynes we'll be getting out there for a
few days
a lot more podcasts a lot more
interviews but every day every morning i
get up i still get my run in every
morning
how do you structure the training the
training is basically structured off of
my schedule so look at my schedule
and i said okay um jennifer what do we
have today
we have this at seven o'clock in the
morning roger that that means i gotta be
up by four o'clock in the morning to run
that's how it works
that's all my [ __ ] works so she lays out
the schedule of events two out you just
you just set it two hours earlier she
says it could take an hour to get to
rich rolls let's say we were at seven
o'clock today in the morning it takes an
hour to get to rich rolls with no
traffic okay let's block into hour 15
for rich roll okay we got that the
morning time i'm gonna run seven miles
this morning
i need uh 52 30 for that
roger that put in
[ __ ] shower shave add that in
so the schedule dictates but
i have always just push it back right so
that means getting up at 1 30.
trust me roger that i've done that
several times yeah
several how much sleep do you usually
get
i i like getting seven to eight hours of
sleep nowadays i can do that but there's
times where the schedule says hey man
you're getting three hours and if that's
the case
right merry christmas first of all your
morning routine starts the night before
so go to bed early but i tried to go to
bed as close to nine as humanly possible
every night save for the weekends
and in that
i sleep without an alarm so i wake up
when i wake up the reason that i do that
is because i want to get as much sleep
as i need so i'm all about cognitive
optimization so
i'm not somebody who sets the alarm to
make sure that i'm up at four in the
morning but when i wake up at four in
the morning i'm a very happy camper
i usually get it used to be between five
and six i'm now getting between seven
and eight i have no idea why it changed
completely randomly and as far as i can
tell without reason uh but i wake up
when i wake up i give myself 10 minutes
to get out of bed and i do that because
i'm lazy and my inclination is to lay in
bed so i need a bright line that says i
get out of bed immediately without
wasting time so i'm out of bed and out
of bed in 10 minutes or less i put my
gym clothes next to my bed so that the
easiest answer is to put my gym clothes
on in fact i'd have to make a conscious
choice not to which thusly would trigger
in me a lot of
conflict emotionally because it is my
identity to immediately go to the gym to
work out again
partly for cognitive optimization and
then also for longevity uh for health
and for aesthetics
but working out i think is incredibly
important and i actually think that for
anybody that wants to achieve something
extraordinary in their life that
the third thing that you need to focus
on is mindset the first two are diet and
exercise
followed by mindset so i hit the gym
first and foremost immediately after the
gym i meditate and the reason that i do
that is because i want to practice going
from the sympathetic nervous system
which is fight or flight which you're
triggering in the gym through the heavy
exertion your heart rate is up your
breathing is shallow and rapid and the
idea is to very quickly switch over into
the parasympathetic nervous system where
you're getting into
rest and digest where you're calming all
of that down you're slowing your breath
your diaphragm breathing
into the nose out through the mouth and
really calming everything down and i
think practicing that transition is very
important certainly uh being focused on
something that you're confident will
have high value to someone else
and just being really rigorous in making
that assessment
um because people
tend to
a natural human tendency is wishful
thinking
um
so a challenge for entrepreneurs is to
say well what's the difference between
really believing in your ideals and
sticking sticking to them
versus
pursuing some unrealistic dream that
doesn't actually have merit and it's
it's that is a that is a really
difficult thing to to tell you can you
tell the difference between those two
things right now so you need to be sort
of very rigorous um in your self
self analysis
um i think certainly extremely tenacious
uh and
um
and then just work like hell i mean you
just have to put in
you know 80 hour 80 to 100 hour
weeks every week
all those things improve the odds of
success okay um
i mean if if if other people are putting
in 40 hour work weeks and you're putting
in 100 hour work weeks then even if
you're doing the same thing you know
that in in one year you will achieve
what they achieve you will achieve
in
four months what it takes them a year to
achieve when you find yourself under
stress
and anxiety things go wrong you get
disappointments
things don't work out as you hoped you
must feel
a moment of anxiety a moment of stress
how do you deal with that what happens
um
i can
go out of the stress
i can at at any moment like there are
times when i i feel the stress of the
circumstances
and then i can
at will
go out of that stress
and just
see things
in a different way and it makes me feel
um almost like a ninja you know when the
in the ninja everything seems to come in
slow motion
you know and in the sense you could step
back and it's coming at me
at slow motion and i can deal with it in
in a way that makes me feel more
centered and in control but like tennis
players they say at the height of their
game
the ball seems to go much slower the
whole game slows down yeah and it's
really
that equanimity
that produces that kind of a reaction as
distinct from
when you have the anxiety
there's not the clarity there's it's all
coming too fast if you practice any new
skill for 66 days in a row through the
power of neuroplasticity which is the
brain's ability to adapt
then you are going to reach a point
called automaticity i want you to think
about that term automaticity in other
words after 66 days of practicing the 20
20 20 formula
and joining the 5 a.m club and running
the morning routine you're going to get
to a point where it's automatic you're
going to get to a point where it's
actually easier to get up at 5am than to
stay in bed
i also want to offer you a brain tattoo
from the book to consider as you wire in
this learning protocol of billionaires
and highly creative people professional
athletes and industry titans and it's
this all change is hard at first and
it's messy in the middle and it's
beautiful at the end i'm going to repeat
that again for you because it's so
important all change is hard at first if
a new skill or a new routine or a new
habit was easy
then it wouldn't be valuable change
so anything that's valuable
is hard at first you know society says
live an easy life i suggest to you that
whether it's a great morning routine
whether it's building a great business
whether it's releasing your master work
to the world maybe it's a great
relationship maybe it's a great interior
life
it takes real effort it takes the long
game it takes focus it takes hard work
it takes bravery
but the rewards are so much more
glorious than living an easy life okay
so and also remember the things you once
found difficult
you now find easy little kids for
example find walking early on difficult
or learning a new nursery
rhyme or learning how to read or
learning how to build relationships at
first there's not a lot of facility and
fluency with those skills because every
skill is difficult at first until you
practice it and then train until you get
to a place where you master it and so
your morning routine is going to be
challenging at first but with daily
training
and practicing the 20 20 20 formula i
promise you you're going to get to a
point of mastery
and then the payoffs are extraordinary
your creativity will soar your
productivity will maximize you will
actually attract more prosperity into
your life because the marketplace
rewards true creativity and productivity
you're going to feel so much more
happier in your day you're going to find
that sense of peacefulness so it's
almost like you go through a life with a
greater level of grace and ease you know
the way you start your day determines
the way your day is going to unfold you
guys are just getting started
you're not going to start right here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town i
grew up in lake charles louisiana no
money raised by a single mother i was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that i had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
first thing i had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that i
improved myself and i could start
depending upon me i had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that i started doing was beating the sun
up every morning
i'm going to beat that sun up every
morning so that i have the discipline
and the control over my life
so i knew hey before that thing pops i'm
gonna pop i'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where i was was beat that
sun up no matter where i am i'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing i had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment when i
was younger between 15 and 25 i was
doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends i had the same
weekends or for the week
i was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people
making poor choices
at 25 years old i cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things
quit hanging out with people that did
not have ethics and discipline in their
life that weren't committed to the same
things that i was
i wanted to build something in my life i
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing i had to do was
become someone i could depend on
so put some things together three or
four things you can do every day to
start the day
kick start your day
get going in your day to give you a
sense of respect for yourself
accomplishment for yourself look just
beating that sun up every morning gives
me the sense of accomplishment that i
did what i said said i was gonna do that
i woke up when i said i would wake up
and i start building respect for myself
start believing in myself so that i can
go out to the world and maybe maybe
maybe today maybe today when i go into
this meeting that i'm dressed for maybe
they'll believe in me as much as i
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some money i
always try to hire people that are
smarter than me and that complement my
skills skill sets like i'm i'm a ready
fire aim guy and i always try to partner
with people that are very anal and
perfectionist to kind of balance me out
or have a skill set that i don't have um
but once i'm going i mean i would go to
events and like this and listen and
learn and go to conferences and when i
get the opportunity i'll ask questions
but i'm not i i can't ever say ever what
i've said
i'm going to call this guy and just see
what he thinks for this woman and just
ask that's just not my style i mean
because at some point i'm going to have
to be responsible for whatever that
knowledge is
and and and also i have the benefit of
being in the technology business and
it's it's a benefit because there's
always something new coming and i've
always had the attitude that whatever it
is so if it's virtual reality if it's
the oculus rift it's new to everybody
except the people who invented it and so
i'm i'm at first base like everybody
else and then it's just a question of
effort of learning it as well as
everybody else so other than going to
the originator of the idea concept
product service whatever
i'm tied with everybody else and having
the opportunity to learn it so i'll just
put in the time to learn it so from a
tech perspective and that that's always
served me well because once you
understand these different products you
understand how they fit together and it
also helps you make decisions and
understand what will work and what won't
work discipline yourself and so what do
you do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time i would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as i've got older i've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because i've
got more and more discipline
like get up early in the morning and get
your things done man learn to get up at
six in the morning and you'll be one
deadly creature especially if you can
get to work you'll have half your damn
day down by the time other people haul
their sorry asses out of bed and so
that's a massive massive advantage look
will ferrell
warren farrell not the comedian warren
farrell the author he outlined data in
why men earn more which is a book i
would recommend by the way showing that
if you work 13 longer hours you make 40
more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them works an extra 10 percent
it's not much
well how often is that person going to
be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss
it's like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously right so these tie
these small edges that you can manage
like that work an extra 10 percent extra
13 percent have non-proportional payoffs
that's part of the pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses i'm too tired in the morning
i don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
google calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also
helps you plan what you want to do so i
could say well lay out your damn
calendar
and
design the days you would like to have
that's what your calendar is is for so
you can put in all sorts of things in
there you want to do and that would be
good for you and that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious
make a plan you need a plan for three
years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour
all of that all of that i make lists
constantly of what i have to do and
they're like daily weekly monthly yearly
right now i can't look out more than
about six months you know because my
life is too complicated and chaotic but
but you need a vision of who you could
be what character you could have three
to five years out you can't go much
farther than that because life is too
unpredictable i think to
make vision that's longer term than that
subject to
there's two too much chance associated
with it to spend a lot of time on maybe
you can stretch it to five years and in
rare cases you can have a 10-year goal
but it has to be pretty low resolution
but you want plans at all those levels
of resolution you want to write the
things down
and what because what are you going to
do you're going to stumble around and
get get what you need you're going to
stumble around and be useful to other
people and it's useful to be useful to
other people you know they want to work
with you then they want to do things
with you they want to have you around
they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel
so that's a that's hell that's a bad
outcome so unless you want that don't
aim for it
and or aim for the opposite because
that's how you get out of it be fruitful
okay this is where business begins the
word fruitful in hebrew means productive
it doesn't mean to have children i was
shocked when i discovered that uh the
first command god gave my hand was what
be
productive in other words produce
something
say it be productive stop saying
fruitful cause you thinking about babies
tell your neighbor be productive
no say this way produce something that i
could buy
that's the first command
now here's something important to
remember
the first command is to be what fruitful
the first command should have been
be seedful
because fruit
is a result of seed
you can't have fruit unless you have a
seed that has a tree that bear fruit
god ignores the entire first step
look at me man just get deep now god say
look i even ain't going to talk about
seed
oh you still didn't get it listen when
god
demands something from you
it exists
so the demand for fruit
is a presumption
that there is seed somewhere the number
one reason why there's poverty
in north cancer
is not because of a lack of investors
coming in but a lack of productivity
inside listen listen here's how you
measure a nation's wealth listen
carefully
a nation's wealth is measured
by three letters all nations
gross
national productivity in other words if
the nation ain't producing
they call it poor in the u.n
money doesn't make you rich productivity
does that's why china is one of the
biggest threats right now
even though they may be poor they are
producing
what do most people in the north texas
do consume
you keep going to the bank to borrow
money to buy stuff that isn't productive
i mean if you're gonna buy a vehicle buy
a truck so you can become one who
collects garbage to produce a business
don't buy a car to drive around in that
ain't productive
the command
presumes
that seed exists
in you right now
there's a seed
that's your business
and god says
show me the fruit of it
produce something
now when you produce a product
watch god's strategy now let's say okay
apple computer
steven jobs pisco because he had an idea
i was an idea
that's your seed
your seed is the idea that it won't grip
this guy had an idea he went to visit
a plant to see a computer
and he went and he saw this computer and
the computer was big as half of this
room
he looked at he says why can't they
reduce that to the size of a desk
and he walked out and he kept seeing
visions
of that great massive computer the size
of a room on a desk
i wonder what you see they won't leave
you alone
write this down every problem is a
business
i'll say it again every problem is a
business
one man see bare feet that's a problem
the other one see a shoe company
that's a business
one man see a hog island
that's a problem
another man sees a resort
that's a business
produce your seed
produce your fruit i don't believe in
toxic positivity i don't believe that
you just like put a positive spin on
things and things will disappear and be
fine that's not how the world works
there are very real challenges that you
may be facing you may be facing abuse
violence you may be up against
structural and systematic racism and
bias and discrimination you may be
facing extreme poverty you may be facing
all kinds of very real and traumatic
things in your life
simply putting a positive spin on things
will not change those very real
obstacles what it changes is you
when you change how you look at things
it changes your ability to deal with the
things in your life it changes your
ability to face hard things and it gives
you the courage and the confidence and
the resilience and the stamina to chip
away at these large obstacles or these
past experiences that created trauma or
negative self-talk it's going to give
you the ability to take the action that
you need and so when you hear me talk
about mindset i want you to understand
this doesn't make things disappear it
actually empowers you to be your
greatest self to face the stuff that's
very difficult you know because
confidence
courage resilience these are all things
that are inside you and you don't build
this stuff
in the high moments you build your
confidence and your courage and your
resilience in the low moments it's like
steel it's forged in the fire of your
life and so even in those moments where
you feel like life is punching you in
the face and you just want to give up
and you have that like i can't handle
this anymore and why does this keep
happening to me i am telling you do not
give up because you are building your
inner strength every step of the way
through these experiences that you're
facing in your life i'm not saying it's
fair i'm not saying you deserve it i'm
saying you have the power within you to
face whatever you're dealing with to
find your strength and to actually
change yourself and the situation and
the trajectory that you're on for the
better taking risk is not just about
going for a job
it's also about knowing what you know
and what you don't know
it's about being open to people
and to ideas
in the course of the film the character
i play begins to take
small steps
small risks
he very very very
slowly
begins to overcome his fears
and i feel ultimately his heart becomes
flooded with love
and i can't think of a better message as
we send you off today
to not only take risks
but to be open to life
to accept new views
and to be open to new opinions
to be willing to speak at a commencement
at one of the best country best
universities in the country even though
you're scared stiff while it may be
frightening it will also be rewarding
because the chances you take
the people you meet the people you love
the faith that you have
that's what's going to define you never
be discouraged
never hold back
give everything you
got and when you fall throughout life
and
maybe even tonight after a few many
glasses of champagne
remember this
fall forward what are some things you
need to immediately stop doing in your
life they are time sunk they are not
passionate they are not moving you
forward but you keep getting distracted
there like what do you need to stop
doing is it watching seven seasons of a
show you know every week is that like
what are you gonna do to get your time
back is it like minimizing the amount of
you know
useless chit chat that doesn't add to
anything in your life like is it social
media is it tv is it just not being
organized like what what do you need to
stop doing to take back control of life
also what do you need to start doing
and what you need to start doing every
day
every week every month every year to be
on your a game discipline buys you
freedom to do what you want so
confidence is in the calendar like take
back your life and get a little more
organized and you have more free time
get a little more organized you serve
better serve better make more money like
these things all add together i know you
know that
so for me i fill out the high
performance planner because it tells me
this is my morning prompts it gets my
mind engaged with the day so i get out
of like that like wandering around mode
it's like oh great okay it sharpens me
up gets me a good attitude helps me
organize prioritize schedule the day
think through it how to deliver with
excellence at night
i review my performance every single
night
every single night i look at my six high
performance habits and i said how did i
do well here like okay how do i score
one to five in these areas and it's not
like every day i'm awesome it's like
there's plenty of days i'm like i kind
of sucked at that one but i don't get
down on myself i'm just aware of my own
performance and by becoming more aware
and measuring that with the high
performance planner i've gotten better
in my life you've got to decide that my
dream is a non-negotiable
you've got to decide that
and and and and you go at it with a
hunger
in order to make it right now with all
the stuff that's happening right now
this this global asylum mental asylum
that we're in right now with the
craziness that's going on right now in
order to break through as dr stan would
say you got to be hungry
people that are hungry are relentless
people that are hungry don't take no for
an answer people that are hungry
unstoppable
you got to be hungry those who hunger
and thirst after righteousness right
thinking right words right feelings
right relationships
and right actions shall be filled
gotta be hungry
to make it right now
you got to decide
it's necessary that you upgrade your
relationships
and and as dr
kareem ellis would say
give a pink slip to all the negative
toxic going nowhere people in your life
give them a pink slip
there's no place for them in your life i
don't take a phone call unless it's
positive unless it's productive unless
it's purposeful purposeful unless it's
profitable
it's got to be positive i don't deal
with
negative people they bring too much
drama with them i don't care if it's my
children no
i ain't got time for it
got to be positive you you you know
something else kareem said he said your
life is not a democracy it's a
dictatorship
people don't get to weigh in
and bring drama to you unless you give
them permission it's a dictatorship you
call the shots
so i call the shots i don't deal with
negative people
then that's here's the other one got to
be productive
as you look in your life and anybody
that's not productive anybody that's not
producing value for you in your life
anybody in your life that's always there
when they need you but when you need
something
you can't find them
no no don't don't bring them
life is like an elevator the higher you
go up you got to stop and let some
people off
let go or be dragged
all right
it's necessary that you do that
and it's necessary that you spend time
with you getting quiet getting still
without developing yourself without
working on yourself without letting go
toxic negative people without a clear
vision of what you want to manifest in
your life
you don't want to do that
no
so you you got to work on you
you got got to get quiet most of us
never achieve our greatness most of us
even don't
know who we are because of weapons of
mass distractions
distracted by foolishness
i can't tell you number of people oh did
you see the fight between roy jones and
mike tyson hell to the no
what am i why am i gonna be sitting
around watching that
what value would that bring in my life
hello
no
you got to use your time wisely
it's necessary that you get serious
about life that you put your foot down
and say i'm not going to be poor anymore
i'm not going to stay in a relationship
where i'm dying rather than living
anymore i'm not going to be a fat blob
anymore no i'm not going to be unhealthy
anymore no i'm not going to be on a job
where they pay me just enough to keep me
from quitting and i work just hard
enough to keep from being fired no i'm
going to live my calling i'm not
mentally fit to have a job a job is what
you get paid for a calling is what
you're made for i'm going to do that
which god made me to do i'm going to bet
on me i'm going to take a chance on me
you have something special
but you got to put your foot down
to discipline yourself
keep your word to yourself
honor yourself honor the greatness in
yourself
this thing called life is serious you
can't be wishy-washy
becoming successful is a slow process
and listen to me becoming successful
is a slow process
developing your greatness is a slow
process
but quitting doesn't make it faster
you gotta decide
it's necessary that you you put your
foot down you said no i'm not quitting
i don't care how many no's i get how
many rejections i get i don't care how
many people tell me i can't do it
even
if i'm not going to even listen to
myself
because i don't have enough knowledge to
know what i can't do sometimes you got
to be intelligently ignorant
no
you got greatness in you
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want 10 more habits that can change your
life check the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there five days
a week will lengthen your life the
telomeres the little shoestrings on the
end of your dna get longer that means
your biological age is changing so we we
have the evidence now